hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
on this thoughtful Thursday I brought a
good friend on to the show
Darren Galvin and down Galvin is the
founder of the property app and we've
been talking to them about business
starting a business
so Darren great to have you on the show
thank you thanks for coming down
talk to me about what you do and how you
got started and and just give me the
background so I've known as the app guy
now and I license social networks to
people anyone who wants them so like
property is one industry our game
football industry businesses brands I
licensed them so they can have their own
social network yeah apps
what is an app it's an amazing tool that
many people don't even realize how
powerful it is I mean everyone everyone
has phones right I mean you know all
right okay
maybe I've got put this proper Cystic on
that ninety seven percent or something
nearly everyone yeah has phones in their
pocket all the time with push
notifications is going all the time and
is the best form of communication and
people just miss it like email rates are
the worst they've ever been because
because the thing is right
I am a property entrepreneur yeah and I
make a lot of money in property as you
know because we're mates but I'm also a
businessman yes and I'm always looking
for that for the new opportunities to
reach as many people as I can to make as
much money as I can to add value to
people you know so I'm really I'm
running a property business but I'm also
a business owner I have a construction
development training business and and
and you're a really good business man
and I think what you've done with with
the leash that you've seen is really
cool so I think the reason I brought you
want today to get to know you a little
bit and you way you came from it's a
great story but also just to share some
nuggets for people because I feel like
people in the property industry
sometimes get so stuck in a rut like I
have to make money through rent to rents
or through hey Chalmers all through or
it's what you've done which is so cool
is you get you started going to some
property networking events and you just
thought how can I bear you to these
people yeah you know I cannot how can i
and that is the true question of an
entrepreneur a true question of
entrepreneurship be hacking on add value
Albert Einstein you know how about
Einstein who doesn't know he said don't
try and be successful trying to be
valuable
you know what do you think of that I
totally agree with it and ever since
being a kid like are you you can go far
back as my school years I've always been
that like how can I improve it even when
like I left school very early no GCSE is
complete failure in school it was just
not for me working on a factory line was
my life that was what I did and I'm
looking at the factory line and I'm
going how can we improve this because
this is just ridiculous
but I was always held back by the you
know the thing is I am it's just not me
like I'm the minimum wage worker I can't
go and change this it's not for me to do
it's for someone else to do alright and
then and I lived that life for a long
time like I look at the factory machine
and go with what probably out for a
million pounds I could improve that and
probably save this company five six
seven million just by looking at the
Machine knowing what I could do but I
always felt limited because I couldn't
do it yeah so I just carried on my life
like this doing all these things all
these jobs and everyone and every time I
look to them and say I can make this
better but I'm never able to because I
can't even get so much as an overdraft
on me bank because I'm a minimum wage
worker yeah and you know I wasn't paying
the bills very well and council tax was
falling behind I've moved out like 15
years old you know it's it was hard
without that's all either gonna make you
bitter and frustrated or make you a true
champion entrepreneur yeah because I
mean I love what you said about how you
spot some and say someone is to do
something I mean I often say if you want
to know what your purpose is in life
your calling and your purpose in life is
to do the things that you moan about
yeah when you see an opportunity no
other the same someone should do this
yeah oh here would be a good idea for
someone it is like I'm doing that yes
and it's the same with like we do a lot
of charitable works if I see something
whether it's homelessness in this
country whether it's people starving or
with no water in a developing country
what they're saying oh isn't that
terrible
someone should yeah I really believe man
I really believe we're the people we've
been waiting for yeah well that's good
weather that's creating the next best
app yeah
whether that's creating the next best
business a charity
social enterprise whether it's just
being a better landlord about parent if
you've seen some thinking you think
someone should do that you got to do it
I think for a lot of people as well they
get this blockage that say that can't be
done and I'm a real believer in
impossibilities like massively yeah some
of the amounts we've saved clients so
recently has been unbelievable because
it's been accepted these are industry
percentages like sales percentages at
twenty five percent when you're selling
from stage like seventy five percent
people walking away from your business I
mean why would you allow that to happen
you can stop that from happening with
technology and what I find is I kind of
have to go undercover a little bit to
actually get in the inside and see
what's going on wouldn't mean undercover
well like I'd started taking up I've
taken up martial arts because we've got
the martial arts that Gordon birch of
these license that and I want to make it
better so twofold I want to really spend
some more time with my family so we do
family martial arts now but when I'm in
there Michael I can see all the things
that we can introduce into the app and
how this will make this better and it's
so good to be able to get out yourself
personally you've you've been on a
massive personal development personal
growth journey the last 12 months talk
to me about that may I have cried my
eyes out so many times this year it's
been unbelievable because like ten years
ten years I just lived I was doing
business right and I stay doing business
it was not winning at all I was doing
websites marketing SEO understanding
myself like I didn't even know that was
under my selling myself and and the
reason for this it goes back to that six
pound minimum weight five pound whatever
from 40 wherever it was I was earning
and then I used to when I then started
in business that I would do SEO
contracts 250 300 quid a month and hey
I'm doing okay now I see people charged
in three thousand pound a month for
exactly the same thing and actually
sometimes are less the standard then I
was doing and I've spent 10 years just
like keeping my head above water
struggling feeling like an entrepreneur
and not being able to get back out of it
because it was a case of I'm in it now
and I'm kind of stuck there's no way I'm
going back to a job
you were you actually worried the job
yeah because I was and you had a
horrible boss who was you yeah 100%
I didn't pay myself yeah people leave
jobs yeah to set up a business but then
really then knew their new boss is all
their clients themselves and honestly I
don't know what the start lifting in the
stats but the average self-employed
person who thinks to a business owner
with average self-employed person that
really just owns their own job yeah yeah
there must be less than minimum wage
100% right because you've got to do my
voice in much less all the all your own
akane and if you want to if you want to
outsource that to other people to
collect your profits so most people end
up doing everything themself the
marketer there's a sales person there
the technician there they deliver their
the customer service there the accounts
and admir everything is working 129 days
you know and if you work out the hourly
rate
it's absolutely peanuts yeah so you were
doing that we met like I don't know I
was a real key player in engineer
helping you turn things around I really
I'm really you know Darren I said this
to you before the I I think people that
can honor other people have helped me
along the way because it's not just me a
lot of people have helped you in your
journey
and I've seen you publicly on Facebook
and out there
you honor everybody and you put your put
your success and you credit so many
people from Hanna I'm just one of the
people in your awesome story and it's a
real honor to be to be that but you know
when you do that it's just I know you do
it from a position of just cuz you've
got a good heart but when you remember
where you came from and you wanted
people that helped you it happens is
they want to help you more it's just
awesome and now I'm saying come on my
youtube show yeah let me let me let me
get you in front of my guys talk about
your app parity yes awesome app you know
because of because of your great nature
so tell them what happened when we met a
year ago and how things changed for you
so itís tough you probably don't even
know actually Sam so when we first met
before that I was like I know I can do
this I've been to a property networking
meeting and I was watching everything
going on
in the room thinking there's so many
problems I can solve I've got the power
to do so with tech but building apps
ain't cheap to be fair it's really
expensive to do and I'm like I know that
a fully functional social network for
property investors is going to be
brilliant and that's what I want to
create so expert empire's 2017 says more
than a year ago now yeah yeah yes so
that was when I first ever had my moment
of like you know I'm going to go along
and I was a bit aunty coaching for the
record aunty cogent and anti mentorship
and that was just me full of my own
problems because I didn't have a clue
that that's what I needed
plus if I'm honest because I was so
broke like literally watching everyone
else doing it it hurt more it was like
you know just I can't do that stuff man
and just like that that doesn't work
like I'm an advocate of mentorship now
because of this because I've been
through it so I remember as a Capital
One credit card or a vanquished one of
them like I they were all hiked up and
then I bought the ticket and I thought
you know what I'm going VIP ticket I
went the top level because and I'm glad
I did because that's why I'm sorry today
because I decided to put myself in a
position that is actually going to get
results yeah there was the the winning
point for me was Nick James had put the
the dinner the night before which is
where we met and I thought you know what
if I don't meet someone there who would
be able to help me give me a bit of
advice then like I'll be very surprised
so I did that and then we were talking I
was talking a little bit around the
table about the property side of things
and I'll be honest I was a little bit of
a nervous wreck like because I was just
little dad like that's sitting there but
no one else knows that no okay well you
know what I think your Milan yeah it's a
little voice yeah it was absolutely my
little voice but I thought Who am I Who
am I to sit here talking to millionaires
around the table that are doing
extremely well that are just going to
look and think well you know what it's
just little Darrin but you were
completely different you know you're
kind nature we had that chat and I kind
of left it there because I didn't really
want to feel like this a big heart pitch
the moment we've met like I don't like
doing that you know so then I was up all
night thinking about like
I can't talk to Samuel about this
because he knows everything about
properties doing really well in property
and actually you might want to get
involved in all this so I think it was
breakfast or there was lunch off
somewhat when we sat down the next day
yeah and you said Sherman you SAP German
his happiest and I know I genuinely
wanted to die because what I had of the
app was the worst prototype you could
possibly show anyone it was like it was
just all free it's like you know
someone's creating an aeroplane and like
this one doesn't fly but it will
eventually yeah it was like and I pulled
this out of my pocket and I said well
this is what it does and it just has
articles in it about property yeah well
why don't you get out of this I can't
Sam yeah I can't get that out there now
like I want it to be a fully functional
social network that's all I wanted I
can't afford to do it what am I going to
do I just get it out there and no one's
gonna want this like look at it he said
just get it out there and it took
hearing it from you to go like he's
telling me just to get it out there and
I respected what you said if I remember
so I just quit you in there cool but if
I remember the app you use and this is
the starting point and you said to me
did you've got 1% done yeah yeah you're
saying when it's fully done yeah I'm
gonna set it for a fortune yeah yeah and
I want to try that's when I'm gonna make
my money and I was like dude man you
doing it completely the wrong way yeah
because if you spend if you spend two
years yeah and put your life savings
into making this brilliant thing there's
no guaranteed anyone wants to us right
yeah I have a buyer yeah yeah yeah and
that's the thing and I learned that
because again when I first got out there
I had to publicly shout out about how to
get people in and I was a bit
embarrassed getting people in but what
actually happened which was a massive
turning point for me was people kind I
think they respected the fact that I
just did it and that it was crap at the
beginning and you know I wasn't crap it
was small it's small yeah okay it was
small but it was also a little bit crap
because it was small things necessarily
didn't always work detective tech is a
really complicated man you know it's
really complicated and it dawned on me
once when someone said to me
one of my license olap license holders
now called Mihai and he said to me
that's actually quite good yeah and I
thought you added the word actually in
there which tells me you didn't think it
would be which I get because like again
I just came from nowhere was just yeah
and as well prior to this I was doing
everything so I was one of these people
that was doing websites marketing SEO I
started writing the book because I saw
every when I was doing it and I didn't
have a clue what I was doing
gdpr came out and started training that
because I knew a bit about it or wanting
to do anything I could do just to get
the money to try and bring this dream to
life yeah so I really lost credibility
in terms of the what I can potentially
do moving forward anyway it's so long
story short and I went I had the burn
right and I described this to people the
burn in the gut that you'll only know
you get when you get it because for me
there's two ways of looking at it
someone says oh you can do it
right and you go yeah I can do it that's
nothing like that means nothing but when
you get that burn in you go do you know
what I can do that and it does take
someone like you to just go just go and
do it and then you get that burn like I
felt the burn yeah and nothing is going
to stop me and I went out and all I
could access was Bank with aqua and
Capital One around an advocate of saying
don't touch them because like the really
high interest credit cards but I did it
at the time because I had to that's what
I did
now it's taken a lot to put out from
that but I made the the plunge and I had
to invest in the technology of what we
had Souls like five ten grand just to
get out there yeah
and now like is to get it but to get saw
but to get where you wanted to get it to
it could have cost millions a hundred
percent yeah and as well like you know
you everyone has ideas right and all day
long you can go to investors and you
know you can say I've got this idea for
a yeah the realism is they're not likely
to go near you if you haven't got much
in the way of credibility and you
haven't built that up in the first place
absolutely and you've actually got
something if you go out there and just
do something and it relates to property
as well if you watch do something and be
seen doing something yeah then
people will invest in it absolutely tell
the world we doing I say this to new
stock property investors most people
they want to be a property investor and
their plan is to be like a secret
property investor yeah and to quietly
get on with it and then when they're
really successful and then become
financially free or whatever terror and
in the same way business people I'm
gonna quietly make this boolean app and
I'm gonna do it in secret
I don't even into Italy for three years
of my life and then when it's perfect
then I'm gonna be rich it doesn't work
like that I know someone and this is why
I do want to do so what I do now is I
license the technology to other people
so they can have their own social media
because I know somebody that spent two
hundred thousand pounds on an app and
the problem is they don't get is that
apps go stale very very quickly because
if you spend two hundred thousand pounds
on an app it's great for now but in six
months when there's more devices out and
you haven't actually tailored it to suit
the new devices what do you do then
that's why I formed the business model
that I say look if you want an out have
an app but will license you out
technology which we pledge then to we
actually upgrade it and keep it
maintained there is a service fee linked
to it but that's what we do so
constantly so you never have to worry
about order and I've seen so many people
just plunge money and that could have
been me I mean if I'd managed to get the
200 grand yeah imagine where I'd be now
like that wouldn't have been a good
place you know here's the thing and by
the way I knew it so many go this last
year what did your up business turnover
250km the first year in the first year
the second year it's been valued multi
seven figures now seven figures Brad
yeah and you main quarter million profit
right 125 in the first year is it the
first day just call me yeah just a
second what you predict tonight the
shell turnover easily well I mean we've
got investors now so where we're at a
stage where we're getting seed
investment so you're familiar with seed
is the drought investing platform so
we're meeting them in July and we're
looking at investment between 800,000
1.2 million wow we're going to get a
lead investor to kick that fund off so
they said anybody to get in
which just it just takes the number so
the bottom line is you know we can
dissect all the numbers but it's
undeniably successful yeah like you
can't say your app business now a
property is not successful because last
year you turned over a quarter of a
million yeah you made a fifty percent
net profit one hundred twenty-five
thousand pound profit this year put it
to be more it's been buried at seven
figures yeah undeniable successful would
have been the lessons in setting it up
and learning and learning as a result of
the last couple years so the biggest one
I would say is just the whole Richard
Branson mantra of just say yes and worry
about it later like realistically when
did we speak about me coming yesterday
Yeah right
I had things in my diary I'm like yeah
worry about that later
yeah my car is in the garage like I'm
not even sure I can get there I'll worry
about that later
eight stock in the morning ring as my
car vetted No okay well I need a cat
give me a car yeah and anyway it was you
know I dusted that's one of my biggest
lessons the other one has to be
mentorship you know and I've got a
credit Nick James for that because you
know the work I've done with him top got
100 percent and matter well you know the
both of them
the we've invested significantly and if
you had said to me a year ago you're
going to spend what you spend on your
mentorship I would have gone no mate not
in a million years am I ever given that
someone that much money but I don't I
don't even look at it now it doesn't
even bother me because like what I see
invest I get back tenfold yeah and I
know that because it's it's quality
event the mentorship and and you know I
think as well it's a bit more than just
quality mentorship it's actually there's
a lot of respect like you know they go
out of the way out of their way to help
you yes so I believe it now I believe in
getting a quality mentor 100% all the
way down the middle but someone who
cares about what they're doing
yeah and that's important to me I love
that I think from I've what I picture of
what you've done
some of esters as well and I said this
to that one when we met just build an
audience yeah you know build an audience
you said you damaged your credibility a
little bit by trying to hear self stuff
that was amazing
weren't really on point of what you're
doing
but then you you helped Brian by doing
stuff like you got people grindcore down
on your show how much did you pay to
have gotten shot nothing
not good no I paid I didn't pay anything
to have gotten caught on my show a good
friend of ours so people 500 thousand
pounds off grant on their show we didn't
pay anything the reason we didn't pay
anything was because we've got an
audience you know secondly I think
before you see for you try and create
something before you spend two years
trying to create something to then sell
it and I said this to you when we met
sell it first then create it 100 percent
because you could create something that
no one wants yeah so whereas if you sell
something first
like for instance you say right I'm
gonna write a book on such-and-such I
don't a book I'm property investing this
is the title ten pounds
who wants in you can even take people's
money from yeah yeah
pre-order it yeah two people do yeah
then you know you know what guys here's
a full refund I'm really sorry yeah if a
thousand people do then it's like right
I'll write the book now and that's a
really important point as well because
there's that's another point I think is
so important is your integrity your
credibility to a tee if you do that and
you try to write a book and you get all
just gift of bloody money back if it did
well you know you know that I know that
there's so many people don't they you
would spend it first and you haven't got
it I like we're talking to ten a book
but this is other types so many people
get investment in and then it like and
they just carry on doing it and it's
just wrong like you the moment you start
doing that there's a problem but there's
nothing unethical about selling those
before creates not at all as long as you
do yeah as long as you create it and
then deliver it in Fault like all you're
doing is you're adding value because
instead of instead of you been so
arrogant to say I know what the markets
but marketplace wants yeah the market
price would love an app like this no no
you know what I don't know what the one
yeah so I'm just gonna ask him what they
want yeah I'm gonna build my audience
yes I know I don't want to ask them and
then when they tell me then I'm gonna
create it yeah
or even sell it in create an anonymous
yeah you know and just get on with it
yeah and even I mean at least get a feel
for it like yeah yeah I mean nearly
closing Academy as we know my elbow so
we're working with him at the moment
creating his social network and we're
doing this I really believe in retention
of trainings you know so if you get
trained then you walk away and you
forget everything then what was the
point in doing it in the first place so
we put it in the quiz in the app so that
you can sort out the levels of training
you can you know you can actually grade
the training you had you can grade
within the app but I think it's amazing
idea by the way so I put out there
asking people first how would you find
this beneficial to scale of 1 to 10 yeah
and yeah like nine ten nine ten nine ten
I might come on to it yes happening I'm
chucking my money in let's do it I was
thinking about the idea of on our
Facebook group offering a thread where
people can sell probably deals to one
another I didn't just do it yeah I
posted what do you guys think of this
idea yeah and then and then I'm
currently processing the feedback some
said good sums are better I gotta wait
up but you know in in business ask
people what they want and then you get
loud it can get loud in to believe in
that yeah I've done it many times by the
way where you just believed it like this
is definitely what people want and then
the dog you know that's not good you
know that's no good imagine like imagine
you've never created a big car company
would never just create a car randomly
no and then just go tada
that research they find out what people
want yeah so yeah so what's next step
for you in business like I said the
investment is the the biggest thing for
us they're amazing and it's something
that like I didn't know was coming and
I've just gotten it it's gonna take us
to another level I want to really just
empower people massively with having
their own social networks because one of
the things I admire about you is you can
get your message out and I do I really
do watch the content you put out there
and the way it's delivered because
that's what I'm now doing a lot of
because data like there's a reason why
social media Giants are worth billions
there is a reason and that is because of
data and I understand data at a level
that many don't know because I see I've
got our own so
for networks I see what goes on and I
know that you can serve clients at a
level that has never been possible ever
yes like never possible before because
you like for example if you want to
serve your clients in the right way you
know YouTube people watching on it the
person who's got YouTube channel knows
how many views they do they know of the
duration but what they don't know is who
is actually engaging with that video and
I know that and I can serve that to
people so that's the message that I'm
really wanting to get out there to
people because when you have that data
you can serve them in a way that's never
been possible before and where the
Giants don't want you to have that
information yeah that's great and that's
my next property app what's the what's
the biggest benefit of downloading yeah
but you know what it's brilliant for
having property investors together right
if you're not interested in property and
you download that you will be the most
bored person you've ever you've been the
most bored experience you've ever had
because it's all about property it's
about property legislation property news
people share in their journey there's a
few deals getting thrown in there now
you can create a group and bring people
into it and it's just like it's fun it's
exciting and there's people doing joint
venture deals out of it you know just
keeping on top of things we push notify
to people so if you've downloaded yet
it's free to download by the way it's
property just drop the why it's an apple
in Google and you download it and then
if there's some really good news or
legislation changes our office would
push through to the notification I know
also the apple lot your little bit your
videos although people love your content
by the way I know exactly who loves your
content because this is what I'm saying
like the power buying that I'm the
people it can can really be serve well
so what we do is the people that love
your content we serve them more because
what's the point in not you know and and
that's how you get people to get a good
experience you like that or dude I'm
really proud of what you've done and I'm
really excited to see where you're gonna
go thank you you're a great guy and I
hope you guys watching have learned a
lot about business about mindset about
startups screw it just do it as a job
and thanks man you're awesome peace out
dad Suns going like you have to give me
some Sun cream before we start
that's thoughtful Thursday that was
around business more southern property
this week if you let me know in the
comments below what you want to hear
about who you want to hear from what
topics you want discussed then drop it
in the comments you tell me I'll make
you happen thanks so much for watching
subscribe I'll see you next time
[Music]